[Music]
Welcome to this topic independent
presents Hi, I'm María Raquel Bossi
Director, Senior Director of Education
and International Initiatives for
Independence
Before we begin our interesting
conversation today about the Argentine film
1985, I would like to acknowledge our
generous sponsors and partners of
this program, thank you  to our
main sponsor the
Hollywood foreign
press association order hollywoodford press association
we also thank our
broadcast platform vision Miriam and our
friends at Amazon Prime video
and now I am pleased to introduce
today's moderator the great
film producer and screenwriter Argentina
Bárbara
mosqueti, well known for her production
of the movie mama and
the screen adaptations of Steven
King's novel it a, which has been one of the
highest-grossing horror movies
in recent years. Oh, welcome, Bárbara
María. Thank you very
much.  honor of moderating this panel with
Santiago miter and Ricardo darín Santiago
I have always followed him but after
seeing This movie is definitely
one of the
most exciting directors of his generation and and and
I can't wait to see what comes
after this and Ricardo darín
has a  transgenerational love like
no one else because
we are fans of all ages not
only in Argentina throughout the
Hispanic world and I think that
now with this great projection of
Argentina 1985 it
will reach unprecedented places and love
will continue because it is unique Santi I am going to
start with a question for you
I think that one of the things that most
impacts the public apart from the
story itself is the tone of the film
and it is a tone that you chose that has a
lot of danger because
depending on where it goes it
can  get to go to the other side
and not give it the respect that the topic deserves,
no, but I think that it is isolated so fine so
fine
that the result is what they are
having now that it is  shock emotion
then I would like you to tell me how you
decided to reach that tone
Well it
is such an important fact
for the democratic reconstruction of
Argentina that it was an issue that you
see to approach with a lot of respect
but above all I wanted to approach it with a
lot of humanity and  try to be very
close to the characters, understanding
well what they could be
feeling at that moment and being able to
reflect that with great precision,
we did an enormous investigation of
about two years, I say because
there was a need to talk Well, as I
said with a lot  precision and in that
investigation two things emerged that
were very interesting, on the one hand,
the formation of the rear team and
the way in which he had to resort
to young people with almost no experience in
justice because the trial was so
unprecedented and the people who  Well,
traditionally they had worked in the
justice system, but they mistrusted that trial a bit
and, on the other hand,  On the other hand, the particular sense
of humor that you had behind,
I mean, they called him the crazy one, which in Argentina
is a way of calling someone who
has
somewhat particular and almost comic outbursts.
So it was something that the
film could use as a good thing,
I am not going to say compensate.  La La La La La
La La The Tragic part let's say that
obviously the film had to
narrate but if it was something that
I think served to
bring the viewer and and and and and well let
down certain guards that could be
related to the
theme anyway I think that  We
use that, let's say, the story of the
family and the particular way he
has of dealing with his
family as a way of understanding and
giving humanity to this character, but
we did not realize that it was going to work
as cosmic passages until the  first
time we saw the film in Venice
where we saw that people reacted to
some scenes almost as if they were
comedy moments I mean  that in that
let's say I realize that it is part
of Ricardo's particular charisma
in the way he has to
relate to his
dinner companions that establishes such
true bonds and we manage to establish
such true bonds between them that
they become  perceives everything with a very natural,
everyday nature and that allows us, who knows, to
smile or well or connect with with
those with those with those
families with those characters in
a very, very direct way, thank you, you're welcome,
and I'm going to add that it's wonderful in
Venice and  I'm sure they had the same
reaction in San Sebastián in London
as that humor that tone
is also understood Beyond the
Argentine borders, not because it's something
very much of an Argentine family and
yet people laugh and understand
What happens to  seeing ourselves allowed to
overcome the barrier of modesty that
can often be felt in the face of humor
in general terms also
allowed us to
demystify a little  especially the
first part of the film where the
number of obstacles that
both Moreno Campo and
the prosecutor's office are behind find on the way
that allows us to reach the
hardest part of the story in a slightly more
relaxed way.
overloaded with drama and also allows us to
appreciate the pulse
of the direction and editing style
where it is clearly noticeable that he is not
afraid of humor because
humor is part of our lives even
in the most dramatic situations and I think
that  This is another aspect that
comes to reinforce the
perspective of the script, which is
profoundly human. It talks about
people, what happened to these
people at certain times in that
context and in those circumstances, and I
think that's what  it makes us
get closer and this is an
absolutely
palpable or understandable characteristic in any part
of the world
since we can count
things from  With a human approach, we are
closer to the audience.
Well, what they have done is really applause
because
they have done it in a masterful way,
Ricardo, now I have to ask you,
you were 20-something in 1985 when the
trial passed, and that's it  You were an actor and you already had
fame.
Did you ever think that you were going to do a
historical biographical character, that is, I do
n't even ask you, it's behind because I don't know if
anyone could imagine that, but in your
twenties you thought about leaving with your
career aside from acting
serious history San Martín Bolívar
you were you had this in your head no
never never ever in fact what happened to me
on some occasions two or three
more were offers or proposals to
face historical figures and I always
escape from that commitment I'm not I
'm one of those  they believe that it is very difficult to
share against reality and in this
case what allowed me not to
embrace this project was
Santiago's proposal first when he spoke to me
for the first time about  what he had in his
head that already moved me and then I
clearly realized that this Barrier
that I always felt with
real people who have existed in this case
did not appear to me as a real
obstacle because the objective of this
story to tell  it is much bigger
than the characters that make it up,
despite its importance and its
responsibility in each of
the sections of the road, but the story that
overcomes all this is much
bigger than any of us.
So that relaxed me a bit  little in that
sense and on the other hand
I felt that by being part of a history
but close to
modern I was not disguising myself Not at all Of
course
but In addition we at all times
knew or felt that we had to be
respectful with the person in question
with the people in question  I don't like to
call them characters because they really
were,
but we reserve a small
or large portion of freedom and
imagination in the recreation.  n of these of
these roles because we did not want to imitate
anyone we did not want to copy anyone
we rescued some aspects and some
characteristics that seemed rich
and very useful tools for
telling the story but we did not want to
invite anyone
Well again now when what I
It happens that when I think one is rear
, your face comes out
[Laughs]
to work on the script to read together
and that to what extent
had to stick to well as it had
been real rear to the modulation he
always had it very clear And the truth is
that it enlightened me in part towards other
decisions of the film let's say the
subject was so important and we had to and
had to work on them with such direct empathy
that we did not have to recharge
much None of the aspects of the
film let's say neither the nor a performance
mimetic let's say that it imitated the
real characters nor in the
reconstruction of the time as we
had to keep everything very in a
very measured tone of some  a way
so that the fact, let's say a
fact like this that had to be
told with so much truth, was
always in the center of the scene and there
were no
dissonant elements and that's what my name is Ricardo Lo you a
lot from the beginning I doubted a lot
about which was the way in which we
had to approach each other but but but
well I think he was right and in the
shooting he is going to tell him now because it
is an anecdote that both of us were very moved
to realize that we are on the
way  correct Yes, well, what comes to
pay for what I just said, Santiago,
is this
on the road, we were having signs
that we were doing things well,
but we had one day, and it is an
anecdote that we always tell, I was
personified from the rear during filming in the
Palace of Justice in Buenos Aires and
we were there for several weeks and during a
break from filming I left the Palace of
Justice and walked down the street
to the Motorhome and I came across a
big married couple and they arrest me they
tell me sorry yes for a second he says yes yes of
course I was wearing a suit the mustaches
the glasses on the back and he tells me I was
a personal friend of Julius Caesar a foreigner
we went to school together we were neighbors
which is why I  I crossed him many
times in my life he says and for a long time
we were friends until many years
later he says and the truth is you don't
look anything like him but you're the same
and that calmed us down a lot as
well as
moved us And it was like good This is
what  it has to be done because
that's what cinema has to do
let's say it's a conjunction of things not
like the artistic fact let's say with the
historical fact Let's say if the two things
produce Well what do I know that miracle of
reliving
what it meant  Julio Rear,
what the trial of the points meant, not
as something that the cinema enhances
the story at one point, serves to
revive it in a way,
especially in this case where the
story  In itself, it is surpasses any
other aspect, that is to say, there are of course
cinematographic cases where it is the
persecution of a character and what is
sought is precisely that
mimicry and we all value a lot
when some actors, actresses and their
makeup team and others achieve a
almost exact proximity but it was not this
case
speaking of projection no
[Music]
the fact of having
a good part of the film with a
point of view
of the youth no that
I have seen I have gotten into a kind
of YouTube hole and I have  seen many
interviews of very young boys in
Argentina talking about the one in the movie
No and
what it means to boys who
had perhaps never had
a serious conversation with this
because they did not live it, that is, the
three of us in some way  we lived it.
At what point in the process of
putting this story together did they
decide that having the look of the
youth of these very young Prosecutors
had to be part of the story
the v  It is true that it was something that appeared
during the investigation but it was like
the Terry Point of the investigation
when that information appeared,
well I knew that this
series by Moreno Campo was well known because they were the
visible faces of the prosecution team
but when I started talking  With people
who had participated in the trial, they
immediately told me Well, you have to
talk to Marcos Omiliana with Judith
Connect, etc. Who were they and of
course they were 20-year-olds and I began to
understand what the circumstance of
justice was at that time,
justice It's good that  wanted and did not
want the trial a society that wanted the
dictatorship to be investigated but was
also afraid that
a military coup would appear again
we came from 100 years of
military coups of military interruptions to
democratic governments So it was a
real risk and it is good behind having
to invent this way to
investigate and accuse in this unprecedented trial
tes had to resort to that
team of young people that seemed to me a very
powerful image to bring to the present
something of the conjunction between what is
carried between this character who during
the dictatorship could not do what he had to
do but now
surrounds himself  of young people to carry out
this research seemed to me to be a
very exciting image and I think that it is as
a political legacy that politics may be
leaving leaving the film is
one of the most
interesting images and it is and is what we
say  When I start to receive
returns in Argentina, I am more
excited by people who tell me if I went to
see it with my 13-year-old daughter and we
stayed talking for hours about it. That
seems beautiful to me and it is something that one
as a cinesa cannot foresee and that
happening is frankly exciting it is
wonderful because what we cannot
forget is that it is
logically understandable that all
those young people who were born
into the Democr  cia do not necessarily have
the
exact dimension of what it meant to
recover it, that is, and we can
never forget that despite the things
that we are commenting on the
humorous passages and these situations, it is
relaxed in, above all, what is the
first part of  we
can never forget that we are talking about
a recreation of a story of a lot of
pain, a lot of pain and a lot of horror.
So the fact that the new
generations have the opportunity to
participate, even if it is through a
film or beyond, of course, through
literature  to investigate that this moves them
that pushes them that stimulates them to go to
investigate I think it is interesting
and it is important from that point of view because
just like Santiago it has happened to me with
countless boys friends of my children
friends of my children of my  friends
people who were born in democracy are
absolutely moved to understand
when confronted with
the great effort that it meant to reach
e  point and what it means from
then on This is a movie is
a story that talks about an event from
the recent past but from the past that
has connotation with what happens to us
today, that is, with the present Not only in
our country but in the  world but if it
manages to reach the hearts and heads of
the boys it is basic and definitely
talking about the future is betting on the
future So that is really how
we have been perceiving it up to now It is
really exciting so
emotional
[Laughter
] that is happening to us we are
talking and  it seems that we are
talking objectively about an event
that happened a long time ago we
are submerged at this moment in
that kind of cloud of returns and
emotion does not pass he is the director,
screenwriter and producer of the film I
am one of its actors and producer  we have
seen the film
many times and it happens to us all the time
it happened to us the other day in London with with
Peter that we were  sitting together in
one in a streaming
and we had been getting along very well very well and we
enjoyed each of the passages
we could even have fun with
some situations and that I and we were
almost amazed and we looked at each other and
said that we are having a good time
because they have already  overcome the anxieties
and suddenly we were left watching a
scene like that we looked at each other sweetly
we began to get excited again that is, it
is the script for me it is a very high point
of this film because I say it ad
nauseam and it seems that they were a
kind of figure  or euphemism But
I think it's one of those scripts that
builds itself, that is, it doesn't
allow
us to get on this story,
recognize it, understand it and absorb it even
if we don't have the slightest idea
what happened at that moment And that
's  part of the intelligence of the
absolute script I send a hug to Mariano
also who is not here but
obviously we do not mention him because
every time we mention him  it doesn't appear
back here
but look and what they say is
what I have no doubt is happening
with the international projection that
this film is having and that I know it
will continue to have is
a word that I don't like to use very much
but  It is really empowering
a generation that many times
feels that it does not cut or puncture, no, no, they
do not know how to alter
the path,
eh, here they are because the
extreme circumstances in which we live
have passed a long time ago, but except
that it continues to happen in  this moment in
Iran in so
many parts of the world is not too many parts of the
world yet that is something also that
we were discovering the projections
outside of outside of Argentina that
fortunately well there have been many is
the film enters one by one in a
crack or in a  wound or in one or in
a way that is profoundly
contemporary is much more Universal
than we thought we have
all societies have have wounds
deep ones that have not been able to heal and it
seems to me that the film, let us say, by recounting
this very Argentinian fact, in turn
manages to be a mirror of the debts that
democracy has in the different
societies and people can
appropriate the film
even though they are not Argentineans and  feeling that the
film is giving is talking about a
topic of universal importance or something like that
because I think it stimulates all
those communities that obviously
feel the need to claim
justice for whatever it is and that
over time are things that are  they take it
as if they were natural and are stopped
and have no apparent solution. It doesn't seem to me
that in that sense this is a
story that by reaching people's hearts and
minds by helping them to
reflect and to know what is
right and
wrong  and it is very good to refresh,
especially for the children, this demand
for Justice Is Universal there are few
places in the world to say none
because it would be daring on my
part where
a community or a society does not feel the
need to demand attention respect
justice truth memory treat  of not
going through the same places they
established never again of this from now
on That is where I think that
this story dialogues very well with
any part with any community in
the world yes and and and also something that I
did not know And that obviously I found out
in this film it was that this trial
is world president in this type of
claim of society
to power to the military because we did not
have it so much in mind Why we did not
have it so much in mind because for some
very strange reason after
40 years  It's almost an issue that was
submerged under people's skin.
But as if waiting latently there,
standby, for someone to come and press that
key to emerge and then
realize that in reality it is an issue that
touches us all
without a doubt And you touched the key with
all your fingers guys it
is incredible and when
we say
the first time in history in which a
civil court condemned a dictatorship
military is something that had not happened
let's say
to The Greek corrals were
different circumstances were either
military justice or military justice itself
or the winners of a war
judging the losers of a war
in this case it was society itself
that  It was a fact that
had no precedent until that moment,
in fact, in all the countries of the
region that did not return,
similar circumstances were not done, they
talk about it all the time, lately they
are talking about it, that is, each one
reviews their own history and  says why
Here we did not do the same because it
could not be understood that each each
place each region each community
needs its own time of madu  ration
For some things but also in that
sense it pushes it
stimulates reflection No I
love it let's say I love it I don't say
alfonsín's courage to make that decision
the judges' courage to say
we are going to do it because they
were definitely people  that they were
doing that you saw then there we go
back to the film at that point
is where that historical fact of such great value
and courage had to be
embodied by human beings with their
contradictions with their fears etc.
view is a
historical value and  political but also of
enormous human value the young the
youngest according to I have what I receive what we
receive
feel a special impact when they
come into contact with a piece of information that
is fundamental in this story, which is
that a year and a half after the recovery
of Democracy the beings who were going to
be judged still had a lot
of power of all real factual economic type and they
were loose This is the reason p  for
which the idea of ​​courage is gigantic, the courage
that all these people had
and that they almost achieved it, apart from
almost not because they were pardoned, that is, Yes,
yes,
subsequent negotiations that
we are still revising today And revising but but
later with the passage of time  time
let's say it came back The cases were
reopened and to this day Argentina
has more than a thousand convicts if processes continue to be
investigated In other words, let's say they
are the ones the process began in 1985
of course there were times
where good there were decisions  which
are now obviously incorrect But they
continue to this day I mean, it
seems to me that it is one, that is why,
let's say, I feel that it is a film
that cannot be caught also
from partisan places and that it is one, it
is a claim and  something that was carried out by
society as a whole And throughout
different stages you saw
So it is a judgment that people made it
But that belongs to the
Argentine society,
not the political parties, because they were,
let's say, what started radicalism, they
continue it, anyway, I don't even want to talk
about those things because, but it
seems to me very interesting, as I
said, sociological, what is the way
in which Argentina faced its
let's say dictatorship or justice confronted
deception sometimes good things are done
in Argentina
many many many other things that are
going to cut me off at any moment but
I continue until they cut me off another thing
that
impacted me was the decision to start the
film  with the doubt of the character not
with the doubt of the back this is not this
we are not going to achieve This is not going to be
done that's what it was called when you work
with well well you know well as a filmmaker
with the musician when we started to
name the  themes the theme one is
called the doubt of it is rear Well since
you mention it it is another is another Clear
description of the intelligence of the script
because the arc of the character of
tr  Asera, in this particular case, speaks
precisely of someone who does not trust that
he is qualified to carry out
such a task, he doubts himself, he is
afraid, many uncertainties, he is
fully aware of the
temperature of the wind chill at the moment
, and the script helps us to understand  what
is the evolution What is the arch of this
man who gets to where he gets and
starts from where he starts from which is
a very low self-esteem
Well nothing the arch is glorious
guys Well there is nothing impressive and
I can't stop thinking  I saw the film
in Venice I didn't want to see the screener they
sent me for this because I'm going to
see it tomorrow at the cinema again in Ross
So I'm going to see it there
talking about the screen I'm a
big screen person not always always
always and and
what has fascinated me in this explosion
of Argentina 1985 and I think
what has happened in Argentina is a great example
that
basically the exhibitors the
big chains decided  n what happened
because the window was small so
all the independents grabbed it and
it has broken all the records
correct yes the truth is that what is
happening in Argentina is something
unprecedented because the film came out with
a good big release
anyway but  without all the
multiscreens that are the ones that
generally have the highest percentage of
viewers or of this audience and
yet we are still in three weeks the
number one film in collection and
people continue to go and produced something that
these are these chances let's say because  It is
something that I would not have decided of
course I think that this limitation in the
number of screens is that people
go to support the film and to want to
share the collective experience and the
full room vibrating with a story so
own so hard let's say abundant
emotion power  a lot about the experience of
the room and I read on Twitter and things that
they send me you saw something like that to see
u cry  An entire room at the time
of Adriana Calvo de
Laborde's testimony is for many people,
it was good for us, but by
many accounts I remember the
importance of the cinema Let's say
as a collective value not being in
a room sharing an experience
cinematographic with other people who are
feeling similar things you saw that
is something that we all like about
cinema and stop going to see as
spectators let's say
and very likely very probably I hope
that is what is happening since you
mentioned it with with  the film at that
level at the level of distribution and
exhibition and others, very likely,
could become a hinge point
in the interpretation that should be had
with respect to certain films in
certain situations Let's not say
that Amazon, who are our partners, is
very happy  with what is happening
in Argentina as well and happy
that the film has this
exhibition in theaters  and encouraging it
to be exhibited in theaters in places where it
can be possible It seems to me that there is a point
where they are different experiences and
that exactly that feedback has to be fed
back and This is going
to have an exponential value on the
digital platform because of how it is  it lived in the
end because of the desire of the people to see it,
also one more point of epic if I know if it
can be said that way as if the
story needed it, it did not need it,
but nevertheless it was granted,
guys, they have given Argentina a great gift
a great gift to the world and to
history
and I have no doubt that it will have a
very long career we are all following them we are
all
supporting the sides
because what they have done is unique and it is
so important
thank you very much we are
proud of that mix  that we were just trying to
describe to you we are still not
that it is not that we
are coldly analyzing this we are we are stuck in a
kind of bubble fed by
our  friends our acquaintances
our relatives the people of of
of of of our activity there is like a
bubble that does not let us get
off we still could not get off
I don't know don't get off keep enjoying it
until the end because this comes with
many fruits
Well guys a kiss and  I'll give you a hug
tomorrow Dale see you Thanks thanks to
you
[Music]